London is one of my favourite places
and every time I get a chance to go,
I take it. When I got invited to the bfa's,
I obviously did not say no.
Landed the night before and the next day we got started on glam.
Love a good fashion moment,
and if the hair needs to be cut,
it's getting cut. I was in glam for about three hours,
took a little break, and once it was time to go,
we started putting on the dress and the shoes.
I wore the most stunning dress by H M.
Studio that just dropped today,
by the way. After taking all the pictures and glam shots,
it was time for us to head out.
Everytime I'm back in London,
I get reminded of exactly how cold it is,
and I was definitely freezing,
but it was all worth it. Once we arrived,
I met so many of you guys,
which always makes me so happy.
This is the last carpet of the year,
which made it so much more special.
Love bumping into my friends
because they make me feel so much more comfortable in these settings.
After talking to all the news outlets,
I made my way up. So glad I didn't wear my glasses,
because that definitely helps with my nerves not being able to see.
Once we were seated, the awards started,
and I'm so happy for Alex and everyone else.